well as everyone else who perished in
today's tragic helicopter crash Canada
stands with you today I am happy to
confirm that Canada will donate another
200 Rochelle Senator armored personnel
carriers to the Armed Forces of Ukraine
valued at over 90 million Canadian
dollars over the past year Canada has
committed comprehensive military aid for
Ukraine including M triple seven
howitzers anti-tank weapons winter
clothes 39 armored combat support
vehicles and most recently a nasam's air
defense system
our military aid totals over one billion
dollars and Canada has committed over 5
billion dollars in Combined military
economic humanitarian and other Aid
so military aid and equipment
which I've discussed training which I've
discussed and the third pillar of our
support to Ukraine is in the area of
Transportation of Aid out of Prestwick
Scotland the Canadian Armed Forces have
delivered over 6 million pounds of
military aid so far on behalf of our
allies their motto is can't stop won't
stop and I Echo that motto here today